a show of china's force in the air and
it's advanced technology
i think everyone cares most about h20
bomber but it's not here
maybe we'll have to wait for a few more
years other than that it's the j20
fighter
[Applause]
j-10 and j-20 stealth fighters are among
the highlights at this airshow in juhai
city
it's part of beijing's drive to compete
against western rivals in selling its
latest military hardware and technology
the main feature of the fk 2000 air
defense weapon system is that it's a
combat vehicle integrated with an air
defense system it has two sets of radar
a photo electric sensor six missiles on
each side and two anti-aircraft guns
it's a show the us is likely to keep a
close eye on
it signed a security pack with the uk
and australia that includes providing
nuclear-powered submarines to canberra
as a deterrent against what they see as
chinese threats in the indo-pacific
region
last week leaders of japan australia and
india met u.s president joe biden in the
white house
the so-called quad is seen as a
counterweight to china's growing
influence and says it's committed to
what it calls a free and open
indo-pacific region
china has also bought military outposts
on artificial islands in the south china
sea in an effort to reclaim territory
that's also claimed by other countries
in the region
back in juhai china shows off its
prototype of the advance ch-6 drone
unmanned aerial vehicles used in
reconnaissance roles and in combat
missions i think that's where the trend
is really heading towards uh for china
in mimicking
the the trends are set by the united
states as a leading military power in
the world
we've seen over the last two decades a
shift towards a lot of
autonomous unmanned and highly
intelligent uh
military platforms
on land and in the sea and and in the
air
industry experts say although many of
china's aircraft aren't yet a match for
those in the u.s air force
beijing is clearly out to narrow that
gap
law about a manly al jazeera